este vídeo lo voy a hacer como una
pequeña observación al problema 5 del
concurso jaime donde cortamos un pedazo
de tronco y vamos vamos a dibujar un
poco lo que lo que estamos haciendo en
ese en ese vídeo
teníamos un pedazo de tronco que tenía
forma cilíndrica muy bien y lo estábamos
cortando en un pedazo de tal suerte que
ocurriera lo siguiente verdad uno de los
cortes era así era un corte transversal
que era perpendicular al eje al eje de
este cilindro y el otro hacia un ángulo
de 45 grados con ese con ese primer
corte muy bien y solo se tocaban en este
punto entonces con esto obteníamos un
pedazo del tronco y lo que yo decía de
hecho lo voy a lo voy a dibujar es que
aquí se obtenía un triángulo rectángulo
de 45 grados en uno de sus ángulos y que
por lo tanto el otro tenía que ser de 45
grados verdad teníamos justamente esto y
aquí éste era un ángulo
y decíamos bueno justamente como tenemos
un ángulo de 45 grados podemos hacer el
siguiente truco podemos hacer un trazo o
hacer otro pedazo otro pedazo de tronco
que coincida de esta forma con otro
triángulo rectángulo y eso se les verdad
y bueno realmente lo que equivale aquí
es haber hecho este corte
y juntar a ambos entonces teníamos
completito un cilindro y realmente
quiero hacer esta aclaración porque no
me gustaría que se queden con la idea de
que esto lo podemos solo hacer si el
ángulo de 45 grados en realidad lo
podemos hacer con cualquier ángulo muy
bien entonces por ejemplo si tienen
ustedes un triángulo de esta forma donde
esté aquí ya es es cualquier ángulo
pueden llamarle theta verdad y este de
aquí es un ángulo recto entonces este de
acá la suma de estos tres ángulos nos
debe dar 180 grados y aquí ya tenemos 90
entonces theta y éste nos debe sumar 90
eso quiere decir que este vale 90 menos
theta verdad porque si tú sumas 90 menos
theta mastretta las las letras theta se
cancelan y nos queda 90 grados entonces
yo también puedo hacer encima otro
triángulo o que en nuestro en nuestro
cilindro digamos en nuestro tronco
equivaldría a ser
pedazo que estoy cortando solo que si
este es el de 90 grados este ya no va a
valer theta en este coincidió que valían
igual verdad los digamos estos ángulos
adyacentes sin embargo este ángulo
completo de esta esquina debe medir 90
grados y aquí tengo 90 menos theta que
debo sumarle para que me den 90 pues
justo debe medir theta y si éste mide
theta entonces este de acá tiene que
medir 90 menos theta entonces realmente
no quiero que se malinterprete lo que yo
hice en el vídeo anterior dije que
usábamos el hecho de los 45 grados pero
en realidad quería referirme a que
entonces este lado es igual a este lado
y es y uno de ellos ya lo conocíamos de
hecho valía 12 verdad pero no significa
que no hubiera funcionado esta idea de
encimar los pedazos entonces esto es
válido este de encima de estos pedazos
encima de los pedazos es válido siempre
que el ángulo sea más chico que 90
grados ok ya otra cosa será calcular la
altura pero bueno sólo era la
observación que quería hacer